- celebrity fathers who have young sons
battling serious health issues we start
with Jimmy Kimmel who had Neil Patrick
Harris fill in for him last night we
have the problem very well Jimmy told me
today that the respirator is out he is
eating he is smiling so all good news
we're after Neil Patrick Harris
delivered the news Jimmy's wife and
mother of the two kids Molly McNerney
brought some levity tweeting today quote
my baby is recovering from open-heart
surgery but I just woke up in a
full-blown panic that I forgot to move
my toddlers Elf on the Shelf he's doing
really great and we're all very happy
about that
we've been with Jimmy throughout his 7
month-old son's recovery including after
Billy's first surgery in April when the
dad made an impassioned plea during the
politically charged healthcare debate
you gave that monologue and talked about
your son you touched so many people no
parent should ever have to decide to
save their child's life his wife who was
a producer and co-head writer of his
show now tells The Hollywood Reporter
quote I sobbed through the entire thing
he came home that night and I just
hugged him and I wouldn't let go
malee also says they got hate mail quote
people were sending letters to our home
attacking both of us saying things like
we deserve this but I think it helped a
lot of families
[Music]